after major public backlash the Hallmark
Channel is reversing its controversial
decision to pull ads featuring a lesbian
couple kissing at the altar now the ads
were for Zola that's a wedding planning
website the CEO of hallmark is now
apologizing and says the company's quote
would be committed to diversity and
inclusion Nikki Beatty says following
this story good morning to you Nikki so
a lot of people have a lot of questions
why did they pull the answer in the
first place
Gail good morning well hallmark said it
initially it removed the ads after they
were quote deemed controversial the moon
came after a conservative group
complained to the network's parent
company that the ads were not
family-friendly I tailor would pick Sola
to happen to host our wedding website a
commercials meant to show a celebration
of love we became the center of
controversy after Hallmark blocked it
from airing on its channel the network
removed four ads from wedding planning
website zola that featured lesbian
Brides after the conservative group 1
Million Moms campaigned to have them
removed to zola ads featuring only
heterosexual couples were allowed to air
notable LGBTQ figures immediately
weighed in on Twitter Ellen DeGeneres
wrote isn't it almost 20/20 what are you
thinking Democratic presidential
candidate Pete Buda jizz tweeted being
family friendly means honoring love not
censoring difference they know how to
celebrate Christmas the Hallmark Channel
is in the middle of its heavily watched
holiday programming I think she was a
success since its season launched on
October 25th the network says it's
reached 50 million total viewers
Hallmark Channel in the past had not
done that before they've been very
inclusive and diverse with their
programming Sarah Kate Ellis president
and CEO of the LGBTQ advocacy group
GLAAD says Hallmark battled - the
pressure from 1 million moms without
doing research on the group they're an
anti LGBT group that only targets
television and film and and commercials
that have LGBTQ people in them Ellis
hopes the
we'll be a lesson on the importance of
representation and inclusiveness I do
think because they took responsibility
they apologized and they did it quickly
that a lot of people will go back to the
Hallmark Channel Hallmark says it will
work with glad to better represent the
LGBTQ community across its brands we've
reached out to 1 million moms about
Hallmark's decision and have not heard
back seems like a no-brainer it really
does I think Ellen DeGeneres speaks for
a lot of people when she says Hallmark
what were you thinking it's 20/20 it was
in the room and that decisions made well
at least you know they've changed course
yes someone as a Holocaust survivor said
to me after the Pittsburgh synagogue
shooting I keep thinking about it and
this controversy is love is easier than
hate yes very true thank you thank you
very much